大家好，这里是珊瑚作用。大家好，我是Sophie。我是三三。
要给大家分享一个好消息。我们的粉丝终于破两万了。
我觉得在一个如此小众的赛道，能做到两万份，挺不错的，给自己鼓掌。
我们反正是对自己挺满意的。
所有的指责批评都拉黑了。
我们其实特别开心。
也没想到，说实话，从最开始，从零到一百的时候，是我们觉得最难坚持的一段时间。
一百份可能有五十份，都是朋友。
没错了。
然后后来就慢慢的到了四位数，然后到了五位数，
然后后来从一万到两万这个过程中，其实比我想象的快，
也是非常感谢我们从最开始就关注我们的这些朋友。
我其实之前一直觉得，应该挺多人关注户外徒步的吧，
因为身边挺多朋友都喜欢的嘛，
但是我其实做了这期博客以后，觉得他还是挺小众的。
没错，特别是像那个，我们在这个过程中也是陆续续的有一些，
比如说品牌啊，无论大还是小的，就是过来跟我们接触，
然后想要聊一些合作之类的，
那可能有一些我们比较感兴趣的合作，
可能到最后人家也并没有选择我们，
就是虽然可能我们非常的垂直，
然后和他这个品牌的调性或者是内容更加的契合，
但是最终也是会选择一些可能粉丝数量级更大，
但是就是更普世的一些这种内容的渠道。
你说的太委婉了，
其实就是户外的品牌选择了根本跟户外毫无关系的，
但是粉丝量更大的一些博客。
虽然这个过程中就是会有一些觉得，
可能挨一下子觉得有些不理解，
或者是有一些些的失望，
但是最后就是我们也选择去坚持自己在做的这件事吧，
无论从内容还是从我们做这个博客的初心。
就是在我们这两年，其实也有很多博客都断工了，
然后就挺播了什么的，
其实也可以理解，因为播客商业化太难了，
我觉得我们俩能坚持下去，
很大一部分原因是我们俩不以此为生，
完全是靠兴趣，就自己感兴趣，
然后所以才能坚持下来，
然后也是自己自费去徒步，
你现在出去徒步，你又没有一种出差的感觉，
确实有，然后山河作用就是经常是以此为借口去团建，
而且现在为了投入产出比更大，
最好是我们俩分开屠播，
这样性价比更高一些，
要不然你看我们俩一起去了坍田塔翁，
然后呢，回来之后最多做两期博客，
为这个博客我们付出了很多，
所以两万分我觉得也是个里程碑吧，
是的，期待今年小宇宙年中颁奖的时候能看到我们闪光的一面，
看来他们是不是能有眼时，
不太好听，
有眼时珠嘛，
期待他们能会眼时珠，
好的，谢谢也感谢大家的关注和支持，
今天来录热热乎乎的坍田塔翁，
昨天还有我们听友斯信我问这一期什么时候出，
因为他也想去嘛，
他问我推不推荐我们那个商团，
我说一言难计，一两句话说不清楚，
所以今天我们就跟大家好好说一说，
我觉得首先说一下，我们怎么知道坍田塔翁这个地方的吧，
我是从石头的纪录片里，
最早可能是从百日大横断里，
然后后来的话，
今年初他又有一个木高迪的荒野计划，
他又去走了一次坍田塔翁，
我把那两个都看了一遍，
我一开始被他吸引是因为这个名字我觉得很特别，
很不像是中文里的地名，
其实我们到了那问相岛为什么叫坍田塔翁，
他也没讲清楚，
可能就有一些传说中的爱情故事吧，
我问了AI，
他说藏语里的意思可能是有草原和平地的地方，
说了都也没说，
是不是因为我们那个相岛太年轻了呀，
可能得问年大一点的人，
有可能，
我们出发前几天就是也很曲折嘛，
因为他不是出了一个公告吗，
他念塔翁封山什么的，
我们已经在所有为数不多能走的线路里，
挑出了一条能走的线，
结果在我们出发前两天，
机票都已经订好了，
突然出了个公告说不让走了，
当时的感觉天都塌了，
然后我们就在这狂疤了，
到底从相岛里拉附近还能有什么线可以走，
因为像虎条侠类似这种线我们都走过了，
然后就不停的刷小红书，
因为当时的时候也很多人还是在继续走嘛，
然后就有人说可以走，
自主重装可以走，
然后又会有人说，
请了相岛的才能走，
就是大家众说分云，
然后因为我们报的是个商团，
还且是当地的一个商团，
然后我就问那个领队，
出发前一天，
然后他给我们的消息确定就是可以走，
然后我们就还是按原计划去继续这个行程，
现在就是国内的所有的线，
像扎干纳、南天山北线这种全部都封进了，
我看那个南天山北线，
大家说法就是徒步者，
就是牧民眼中移动的奖金，
一个人就是五百块，
说就是几乎很难有漏网之余，
因为山上的牧民现在非常多，
你就算走进去三天也能被逮出来，
然后看很多朋友分享就是被逮出来的时候，
在外面等警车了过来接，
然后牧民还非常好心，
邀请他进帐篷里喝奶茶，
最后变成派出所打开一日诗，
所以大家还是反正尽量别抱着脚心心理吧，
选一些安全技术高的路线，
所以他念他翁这个地方，
他其实是处于横断山脉，
他可以说是在川西和西藏的交界的地方，
我们徒步的路线是从乡格里拉进，
然后从西藏出，
就是他的那个起点就离云南很近嘛，
大部分人是从丽江或乡格里拉包车过去，
然后出的地方的话，
会离左贡线，然后昌都市比较近，
大概是处于一个这样的地理位置，
算是一条藏东的徒步路线。
因为我当时去德格的时候，
我穿过那个隧道过去就是长度了，
我觉得得说一下，
他这个交通真的确实不是很方便，
因为当时我们研究了很久怎么走这个事儿，
我们从北京飞乡格里拉，
首先他是没有直飞的，
为什么没有直飞呢？
有可能的两个原因就是，
从北京飞乡格里拉，
首先人没有那么多，
你得先飞到成都这种地方，
把大家要去乡格里拉的人聚集一下，
然后其实还有一个说法，
说西南是东航的大北营，
不知道是不是准确的，
反正从北京飞乡格里拉一直就没有直飞，
好像丽江有过，不知道现在有没有，
他肯定不是技术原因做不到，
因为飞昆明都有直飞，
昆明其实比乡格里拉更靠南，
但是他我估计还是客流量的问题，
对，然后首先第一天，
我们就要从北京飞乡格里拉这一天就没了，
然后第二天从乡格里拉，
因为我们报的是一个商团，
他会有车接我们去取资卡，
取资卡其实已经属于昌都市的盲康县，
我们中间是经过了一个。
从云南进西藏的界，
当时我们问那个司机说，
我们从乡格里拉开到取资卡多久，
他说最快的话五个小时，
结果开了九个小时，
其实所以早上八点出发，
到那其实已经是下午了，
一天时间又没有了，
然后第三天，
要再从取资卡，
坐一个小时的车往山上走，
然后走到一半，路被挖烂了，
然后我们要所有人下车，行李也下车，
再换一个山上的车，
把我们接上去，
这里有个很有趣的知识点，
最近大家可能也在网上看到了，
在汤林汤门会有一些，
到底能不能进山，
是不是封山的一些争议，
所以进山的这个过程，
确实比较周折一些，
而且说到这个进山村口，
这段巴滥的路，
也有人说是有人有意为之，
就是那个路，
其实并不是必须要施工的，
也没有人在那施工，
它只是滥在那里，
刻意让你必须要换成村内的车，
才能进村，
我觉得有这个可能吧，
所以就是非常的麻烦，
甚至我们换了车，
说以后再往拉岗村走的时候，
行李还掉了，
有一个朋友的行李，
从山坡上滚下去了，
因为我们的那个驼包嘛，
就是摔在了车顶上，
他可能就觉得，
这么一小段山路，
也没必要绑得很紧，
结果就翻下去了，
第一个掉的时候，
司机没有发觉，
然后第二个掉的时候，
他才发现，
他又把车倒回来，
去捡那个包，
然后他一点数，
发现还少一个，
然后又打电话给山下，
那些骑摩托车的同伴，
然后那些同伴，
行李捡上，
然后又抱着行李，
开上来。
其实刚才说，
我们坐车进山，
我们是从曲子卡住了一晚，
但是我看大部分，
商团也好，
或者重装的人也好，
他们会选择，
前一天就到拉岗村，
然后在拉岗村住一晚，
第二天一早直接就走，
但是在拉岗村住一晚呢，
住宿条件就会相对来说，
比较有限，
就是那种村民家的大通铺。
但是曲子卡是一个温泉厢，
你就可以住到，
还可以的那种温泉酒店，
还可以泡泡温泉。
是，所以这个，
大家可以，
根据自己的时间安排来。
因为也不差，
早上那一个多小时了嘛，
因为从曲子卡开车，
到拉岗村，
大概一个小时左右。
然后到了拉岗村之后，
我们其实就是，
换上了马帮，
开始正式的徒步了。
如果说到这个交通，
我是觉得，
其实心里一直在跟别的路线，
在做对比啊，
比如说像ACT，
我们是北京飞家的满渡，
一天就在飞机上了，
中间可能要转机，
这一天时间没了，
然后第二天呢，
从家的满渡，
包了个机铺车，
到我们徒步的起点，
上批丧嘛，
一天12个小时没了，
其实也是整整两天时间，
然后第三天一早，
就开始徒步了。
是,
但是我会觉得，
稍微好一点的，
就是它这两个段交通，
比较整，
它不是被切成了那种碎片，
然后包括我们去TNB的时候，
也是你北京飞日那碗，
不管你是直飞，
还是转机也好，
你到了以后，
比如说你中午到了，
你下午坐个大巴，
一个小时也就到，
下午你了，
你甚至到了第二天，
你就可以从，
下午你一开始徒步了，
当然你飞欧洲的时间，
会比较长一点，
它可能有八九个小时，
但是它也是一个整段的交通，
它不是把它切成很碎的那种碎片，
就是你如果交通太碎了，
你又是坐飞机，
飞机要转机，
又要坐机铺车，
然后要坐好几段，
就会觉得特别累，
所以这个交通，
其实我觉得，
并不是很方便，
虽然它是在国内，
所以就有人说，
他宁他翁，
他的交通成本，
其实是蛮高的，
我们刚才讲的，
这是晋山嘛，
其实我觉得，
出山是更漫长的，
对，出山也很费劲啊，
出山比我想象的，
要长很多，
我们是最后从，
这个地崩营地，
然后可以包车出山，
然后从，
地崩营地，
要坐一个小时，
那种沙石的山路，
然后到沙多村，
然后从沙多村，
又换了一辆车，
把我们拉到左贡线，
这个又花了四个小时，
到了左贡线，
你就以为，
应该是离繁华，
或者离这个交通书纽很近吗？
没有,
从左贡线，
到昌都市，
又有一个四个小时，
他在左贡线和昌都市之间，
是昌都机场，
所以你如果赶开机的话，
大概要预留，
两个半小时，
到三个小时的，
车程的时间，
那是我见过最远的机场，
那确实是中国，
好像距离势力，
最远的机场，
两个半小时，
太可怕了，
我们坐早上，
八点五十的飞机，
四点半起的床，
五点出发，
七点半到的机场，
你去了新疆和西藏，
才发现中国真大，
而且费用也不便宜的，
当时我们从地崩包车，
到左贡线是一千二吗？
一千二一辆车，
我们只好五个人，
平滩了一下，
然后,
如果你才从左贡，
去昌都机场是五百，
再去昌都市区的话，
是八百，
所以这个交通，
假如你出山，
你说我要从地崩，
就是去昌都市，
那包车就得两千，
是,
所以就是这个时间，
和金钱的成本，
确实都挺高的，
对，像我们从北京出发的话，
就会觉得来回的交通成本太高了，
所以当时听说，
就是有可能进不了山，
就很崩溃，
就万一，
飞进巴拉的，
到了村口，
然后不让进，
但是真的是想哭，
而且附近没有别的，
可去的地方，
确实,
但是好在，
我们还是顺利进山了嘛，
这次进山呢，
有一个前提条件，
就是我们进山那天，
才知道，
他们的活佛，
求了雨，
说因为他们最近的装甲，
一直没下雨，
装甲太干了，
所以活佛求雨了，
说明天就下，
精准的下到了我们的头上，
一开始，
我们还听听，
就觉得，
活佛求雨了，
就是觉得，
是一个跟我们，
好像没什么关系的一件事情，
没想到，
活佛非常零件，
我觉得这个活佛，
值得信，
我们在里头走的六天嘛，
活活下了五天雨，
而且雨是越下越大，
一开始几天，
下完了就停啊，
偶尔还能出点太阳，
我们就还抱着一种希望，
然后在那个营地，
有一个朋友，
给了我们一个到家的，
收宇宙，
说出来的有点好笑，
然后我们就在那儿念，
背负啊什么的藏名，
他们看见我们在念，
收宇宙，
都觉得很好笑，
我们号召营地的，
其他的朋友，
跟我们一起念这个收宇宙，
而且念完了以后，
还看到了一点，
雪山,
就觉得，
哇，真的管用了呢，
现在在用到家，
对抗佛教，
就是在人家的地盘，
请一点到家的力量，
对，到了第五天的时候，
那个雨，
彻底放弃了，
那个雨真的就是，
已经把人下崩了，
就是完全不带停的那种，
又是风，又是雨的那种，
而且还发生了一个事儿，
就是我的包上，
一直挂了一个，
我自己缝的那个，
求雨亭的一个遇手，
挂的包上很久了，
进山的时候丢了，
好像就第一天挂在上面了，
后面就一下子，
不知道丢到哪去了，
可能是走小树林的时候，
挂在哪了，
然后就掉了，
当时我就觉得，
大事不好，
这是一个不好的预兆，
然后我还有一个，
我们的朋友，
给我发微信说，
你和三三的组合不行，
谁?
他说，你俩不行，
现在验证下来，
就是我们俩这个组合，
真的不行，
我们俩不能单独出去，
实锤的就是天气之子，
缝我们俩出去，
避下雨，
对,
我们俩第一次爬富士山，
C级天气，
去长潭岛潜水，
遇到台风，
后来回城的航班，
还取消了，
反正就是各种周折，
不好意思说，
去长船避，
也赶上下雨，
下了三天雨，
基本上天气就是这样，
我也看了一下，
我包上有个温度计，
晚上在木屋里的，
温度可能在五度左右，
唯一有一晚，
是在双湖营地，
因为它海拔比较高，
是四千七百度，
它可能会接近零度，
然后白天的话，
我觉得也就十度，
十度多一点吧，
然后如果出太阳的话，
会明显体感暖和很多，
可能就有十几度了，
就是六月底的话，
差不多是这个温度，
可以说一下海拔吧，
除了拉港村，
大概是三千出头，
基本上第一天的营地，
就已经四千三，
四千四了，
后面基本上，
就没有再低于四千，
就这个，
真的算是一条，
非常正儿八经的，
高海拔徒步路线，
而且我们翻了四个崖口，
都是将近五千海拔，
就是什么四千九百五，
四千九百七，这种，
对,
我觉得可以介绍一下，
整个探紧探望的这个线路，
因为探紧探望，
它其实分好几个线路，
比较常规的，
就是我们走的这个看海线，
然后它还有更，
应合的叫沿灯线，
我们就讲，
我们走的这个看海线吧，
其实它，
顾名思义，
它就是以看海子，
看这些高原的湖泊，
为亮点，
然后中间的话，
会看到好几个，
就比如说像，
最有名的就是柔错嘛，
整个线路它加起来，
其实它的距离，
我觉得，
算是比较轻松的，
它说是，
虽然说是五十多，
但我们实际走下来，
是没有到五十，
可能中间有一个原因，
是因为我们，
跳过了五个曲龙营地，
直接从它横切过去，
然后从南加拉牙口，
直接横切到珍拉牙口，
然后连爬两个牙口，
到了双湖营地，
等于说，
把中间这一段路程，
可能缩短了一些，
所以我们六天，
大概走的是46公里，
我的手表记录的话，
爬升是3225米，
下降2430米，
其实这个强度，
就还好，
因为我们每天，
基本上，
一两点，
甚至有一天，
12点就到营地了，
就几乎没有，
超过两点到营地了，
嗯,
每天下午咸的，
了不得，
主要是还下雨，
就也不知道干嘛，
然后我们一共五晚嘛，
住了三天的木屋，
然后两晚是大帐篷，
我觉得还可以聊一下，
我们报的这个团，
和我们其他，
之前报过的商团的差别，
我觉得可以，
开起一下兔草，
首先哦，
在藏区的人，
都不太有时间观念，
我觉得这是很普遍的，
不能光苛责，
就是我们报的这个商团的，
比如说，
我们已经告诉他航班号了，
他就说，
我要来接你，
当我们落地了以后，
给他打电话，
他说,
嗯，我还有40分钟到，
哈哈哈哈，
就是类似这种，
就类似这种事情，
我觉得，
反正,
我都不会觉得，
是有问题的，
反正,
我们不想等了，
就自己打个车，
然后就直接走了，
这种事情，
我觉得对这个团，
我最大的问题是，
他们,
号称自己很专业，
然而并不是，
就是,
他的宣传的卖点是，
他是有证的向导，
但是呢，
实际,
陪我们走下来的，
就是当地的牧民，
当地村里的朋友，
他们绝对不可能是有，
向导证的，
他们没有向导证，
对,
然后呢，
他们还会说，
配备了什么样子的，
比如说，
专业的设备，
然后像，
卫星电话，
像这个，
氧气,
像什么，
这个救援装置，
之类的这些东西，
结果是，
因为三三这次，
自己租了一个，
卫星电话带过去，
然后向导全程，
在借他的电话用，
然后最离谱的是，
我从来没有，
参加过一个团，
中间要换人，
我们去之前，
不是出了一个，
通告的时候，
不让走了吗，
就有的人就说，
是村民之间的利益纠纷嘛，
然后我们去走的时候，
才真实的感觉到，
这个利益纠纷，
是怎么回事，
一个团，
甚至被切成了两段，
就是因为，
前两天，
属于拉岗村，
所以只有拉岗村的，
马夫和他的向导，
能到,
然后到那个营地，
再往后走的话，
会属于沙多村，
这时候就要有，
沙多村的向导，
和马夫来接我们，
中间是没有交接的，
然后我们也是被，
临时通知，
明天会有一个新的，
向导陪你走，
然后第二天的向导，
他就回去了，
他跟马夫一块回家了，
对,
然后我们就在营地里，
等新来的那个向导，
来找我们，
对,
然后新来的马夫，
牵着马来，
中间甚至，
比如说，
向乌格耿龙那一站，
牯因为又属于，
另外一个村，
沙多村的向导，
就很不想，
去走那个村，
过那个营地，
就厌过把毛，
你只要是，
一匹马就要负40，
一定要摩托车都要负40，
就是说那边的人，
非常难沟通，
我们这次听了很多他们，
村人的人，
互相抢，
这方村的，
就算是，
每个村都讨厌另外的村，
所以我们突然一下，
就明白了，
出这个文件说不让走了呀？
或者说村子之间利益纠纷呀什么的。
因为所有村可能都想要。
大家从我这儿报名。
对
然后呢？
我来赚大头
然后他在往下分销。
然后现在我们前半程是跟着拉岗村的向导走。
然后后半程是跟着沙多村的向导走。
沙多村的向导就一直在跟我们说。
他在计划一个自己的徒步路线。
从沙多进出
然后如何
这样可以避开拉岗村。
对
如何走这个精华线。
因为就是用他的话说。
前两天根本没有任何风景啊？
你干嘛去走那段路程啊？
就没有任何意义
但是问题是沙多村呢？
他又刚像刚才说的交通又很不方便。
他如果从昌都进出。
首先他的飞机非常少。
然后他的路程又非常长。
就是很多这些需要考虑的实际因素。
所以当时我们走完了以后的结论。
就是这条路线只适合重装。
重装你就完全不需要考虑这些问题。
你不需要跟村民打交道。
你也不需要跟背负打交道。
你就走你自己的就行。
没人管你
你就是负点营地费。
负点垃圾费
而且我甚至想了
以后我要去的话
因为那个路线路际很清晰嘛？
你完全可以自己走嘛？
就顾个马
就把包背着
你中间要换马要
对
而且他这条路线有一个问题。
就是他没有信号
就是你如果有这种。
就是比如说中间牵扯到幻象的。
换马之类这种问题。
你中间是练习不到任何人的。
而且你换向岛的时候。
是你不能决定你用哪个向岛的。
就是他们村会有一个。
排版表
对
就是他们能当向岛的年轻人。
都排在那个list上。
他们的村长会分配。
就该你了就你去
所以你会被分配到一个什么样的向岛。
是完全未知的
对
我觉得还好分到我们的一个向岛还可以。
因为他就是比较年轻。
然后他那个汉语讲的也比较好。
因为我们旁边有一个团。
他就分到了一个汉语。
说的不是很好的一个向岛。
就完全没法沟通
所以他不停的要借我们的向岛去。
跟他们沟通
就像刚才说的
因为原本这条线路中间。
有一碗是住在一个叫乌鸽取龙的营地。
因为他们村和村之间的利益纠葛。
所以这个向岛就跟我们说。
我们下一晚不要住乌鸽取龙营地了。
因为你们走得很快。
所以我们可以把两天的路。
成合并成一天
然后第三天
我们可以去看多一点的孩子。
就是在你没有任何手机信号。
没办法查任何信息的情况下。
你只能是听他的一面之词。
来去选择去信任或者不信任他。
说到这一点让我特别不习惯的是。
比如说你问他明天早上几点出发。
他会说看你们
随便 都行
我想说你没点计划吗？
然后说明天走哪个线路。
他就说都可以看你们。
想看什么 都行
就是我从来没有报过哪个商团是这样子的。
所以我就回头去看了一下出发前。
给过我们这个录书。
就觉得他录书就是瞎写。
他应该就是超过来的。
因为他很多地名
他是前后的顺序都是错的。
对 然后他的爬升多少。
距离多少都非常的不准确。
跟我们实际走下来看的话。
然后一般的商团
他除了有向导
一般是当地人
他可能还会有配一个领队。
领队的话可能就是。
坏经验丰富一点的这种年轻人。
他可能不是当地人。
他就会有领队去跟向导沟通。
但我们没有领队这个人。
我们是直接跟当地向导沟通的。
所以有时候会有一些沟通的问题。
像我们遇到的这两个向导。
中文都还不错
然后你遇到马帮什么的。
其实有时候他们中文不太好。
你可以理解
因为中文对他们来说算是第二语言。
尤其是对于一些年纪比较大的马帮的人来说的话。
就像我们刚开始学英语的时候。
有时候会说英语
会比较粗鲁一样
他说中文也会这样。
我记得当时隔壁队的马帮在跟。
他们的队员沟通的时候。
他就说这条线路很难。
你们不要走这条线路。
他说的就非常直接。
他说我们
他说他们有微信电话。
你们有吗？
他们有微信电话
出了事他们可以打电话叫人。
你们出了事我可不管。
我是马帮
人死了我不负责
就是那个话非常之难听。
我在旁边听了以后我都震惊了。
当然他因为他不太熟悉普通话。
所以他表达起来肯定不像我们表达起来那么准确。
所以这些都是问题。
如果你有一个领队的话。
能去跟当地向导沟通。
你就免除了这些
他们有领队
对
我们全城同期在走的隔壁的团。
也非常奇葩
就是遇到了很多很奇怪的事这次。
他们的领队在第一天就说。
这什么团
我好想下车
我可不想住张鹏
那个领队好像之前。
经常带一些欧洲的二杯丝什么的团。
就是他非常看不上这条线。
就是吃不了苦的那种。
对
他说早知道是这个条件。
我第一天就下车了。
领队第一天就要下车。
这些当地向导
他其实很有高原生活的生活经验。
但是他未必经过专业的培训。
他的生活经验包括比如说下大雨。
他也能把火升起来。
非常会生火
像他们生活的时候的方法。
当时下了我们一跳。
因为当时下大雨
柴特别湿
然后就一直点不着。
他们就捡营地里
别人用完的那种高山气罐。
可能里头还有一点点残雨的气。
他们就用石头把气罐砸。
砸一个孔
对
这时候你就能听到气撕出来的声音的。
那一刹那
他把它扔进火里
然后就轰了一下
然后就炸了
那火焰就穿得老高了。
然后就靠那个火焰把柴点着。
然后可能丢了七八个这种。
高山气罐进去
然后每当他要丢
然后我们就啊的一声。
然后四三
然后看火平吻下来再做回来。
然后过一会他又要丢一个。
我们再啊？
他们有这样的生存智慧。
比如说对天气的判断。
你要问他说明天是什么天气。
他可能没有办法回答你。
明天是下雨还是晴天。
但是当天的时候
我觉得他们对于天气的判断是很准确的。
因为第一天在伊兹崩营地的时候。
只有第一天的伊兹崩营地。
你往回走100米是有手机信号的。
在一个山坡上
你一到那个山坡上站住立刻就有手机信号。
但是当时在下小雨。
我觉得哎呀下雨了。
我要不要回去拿雨衣。
然后他就会判断
他觉得这个雨不会下大。
然后等我们刷了一会手机的时候。
他会说赶紧走要下大了。
他能预感到这个雨是会下大的。
就是他可能没有办法预判未来几天的天气。
因为山里的小气候太多变了。
但是当时的那个天气他是能预测到的。
包括在地崩的那天早上。
我们的厨师进来以后说。
今天是个好天气
我当时就想说肯定没跑了。
就是因为他对天气的判断肯定是更准确的。
但是他们可能对于高山向岛。
应该具备的一些东西并没有那么的专业。
比如说你带团的时候。
应该以一个什么样的节奏或者强度来带这个团。
你多久休息一次
你是坐下来休息还是站一会休息。
如果遇到一些突发情况。
你应该怎么处理
当然我们这次没有这些事情。
我们这个团其实我们三个女生一起去的。
我们三个朋友
然后另外还有两个女生。
就是我们五个女生。
然后大家一个是年纪都比较轻一些。
然后也都相对有一些之前的徒步。
包括高海拔徒步的经验。
所以整体而言
我们五个人的体力是相对比较平均。
然后徒步的能力也是比较强的。
所以向岛也说我们这个团是他带过最省心的团。
他说我们比无景走得还快。
因为我们每天就是中午就到营地了。
屡次刷新他们徒步的最快记录。
像我们翻两个牙口那次。
他们预测我们可能要6个小时。
结果我们
5个小时
5个小时就到
然后到营地以后
那个马夫还有厨师长都列队欢迎。
跟我们直述大拇指。
说你们太厉害了
确实就是说到他在做向岛这方面的经验的话。
像之前我们走天壁。
然后我们那个向岛Claire。
他是那种专业的高山向岛。
他就会非常有经验的去把控你整条。
队伍的行进的速度。
然后他会知道大概走。
比如说一个小时或者一个半小时停下来10分钟。
再走一段时间
我们再有一个长的break。
然后这时候他就会非常明确的告诉你。
这个停顿是只是停下来休息一下。
还是要坐下来吃东西。
但是跟着这一次的向岛。
就是他是完全没有这个概念的。
他就会走在前面
而回头一看
有人落下了
他就会站在那等
但是可能对于像我来说。
我比较习惯按照自己的节奏去走。
就特别是爬坡的时候。
我不习惯就是那种走走停停。
我比较习惯就是按照一个速度。
是可以是很慢
但是一直不停的往上爬。
这样对我来说是一个比较节能的方式。
所以到最后我就跟他说我不休息。
我继续慢慢往上走。
这样的话我会个人的体验会更好一些。
所以像这种专业的培训的话。
我觉得他们会比较缺乏。
包括可能对高原反应的一些处理。
我不觉得他们会有很大的经验。
因为他本身生活在那。
他没有这个困扰
我觉得还有一个就是。
比如说像我们说的。
无痕户外这种吧？
他会尽量说你要走在图不到上。
不要去偏离图不到。
去走一些小道或者是自己开道。
因为这样你会破坏高原的纸背。
但这一次我们走了超级多的小道。
我觉得我踩死了非常多的高山图卷。
没有办法向导
就是带着你走这种路。
因为对他来说到处都是路。
他没有任何一个保护纸背的意识。
我觉得这个对他们来说已经是太超纲了。
如果你能做到不乱扔垃圾。
甚至是把垃圾带下山就已经是120%了。
我觉得以我对他们的基本的要求来说。
所以我是觉得他们其实还是需要一些。
高山向导的培训
就专业培训
要不是说我花钱去买个登山向导证。
这个就是一个反正很难讲的一个体质性的问题。
我也不觉得他们有处理生活垃圾的能力。
有一些营地他会说就扔在那吧？
会有人来收的
但是他甚至不会用袋子把它装起来。
他就是直接撇在地上。
就是会看的非常难受。
所以从第三弯开始。
我基本上就把我自己的垃圾都装在脱包里了。
就没有扔在营地里。
没错
其实这个也是你需要有一点自己的判断。
就是你这个了
如果他是纯野生的那种营地。
他连牧民连牧乌都没有的话。
就是尽量不要把垃圾扔在那里。
即便他跟你说就是会有人来收。
你因为你保不起是不是就有马。
或者牛过来把你这个袋子啃破了。
然后你明显也能看到那个营地的。
会散落一些那种临时的垃圾袋什么的。
如果他们是做到的清理的话。
为什么会有这些一看就放了很久的。
在野外待了很长时间的那种临时垃圾袋。
还会在那个营地呢？
对
所以我觉得他们处理垃圾的能力也一般。
所以尽量还是把自己产生的垃圾带走。
而且我觉得比较逗的一点是。
就是在我们第一天进山的时候。
我们那个巷岛
他其实一路都在捡垃圾的。
对
因为这个巷岛身份也比较特殊。
因为他是我们住的第一晚。
那个伊兹奉营地的Owner。
叫什么 农场主
他就是那个伊兹奉营地的老板。
所以等于说这一路就是。
如果有垃圾的话
他其实是要负责的。
所以他在我们爬升的一路的过程中。
都在不停的捡垃圾。
然后他也有在说
说其实他知道这些垃圾大部分都是藏民和马帮扔的。
游客和重装徒步者扔的垃圾比较少一些。
他也是表达出一些比较无奈吧？
我觉得这个对于当地人来说。
这种不乱扔垃圾的概念。
或者这种教育还是是一个长期的问题。
其实你能看到明显是谁扔的垃圾。
比如说是能量胶的那种包装。
那肯定是游客
对
然后像什么红牛的瓜。
这种有可能是当地马帮他们自己。
没错
我觉得就是一开始。
马帮扔的那些瓶子什么的。
看起来更多一些
到后面越走
一看就是徒步者扔的垃圾。
比如说像什么山牧的小零食之类的这种东西。
还有一个他们不专业。
你像我们是自己带的帐篷吗？
我觉得这个是一个非常明智的决定。
幸亏我们当时自己带了。
原本我们报的这个团案。
按理说它应该是提供帐篷。
睡殿和睡袋
所有的这些睡眠系统。
它都以及包括吃饭。
所有这些都是全包的。
但是我们就是因为。
比较穷讲究一些
就想说不想睡他们的东西。
然后还是自己带吧？
因为自己都有这些装备。
我们就跟他们商量说我们自己带了。
反正就是行李的那个重量也没有超。
幸亏是自己带了
它给另外两个女生提供那个帐篷。
没有地丁
最后用一次性筷子当地丁。
睡袋是闭绵的
根本达不到她要求的零下十度的温标。
但那个很沉
我感觉有十斤重
然后那个女生第二天早上说。
冻死了在那个双户营地睡的。
他们只有一个防潮店。
好像也没有气垫什么之类的。
然后他们有一个公共的帐篷。
是给厨师做饭用的。
那个帐篷非常小
而且漏雨
然后有一天下雨的晚餐。
我们就是蹲在帐篷里面。
但也没法做
因为都是湿的
然后也没有凳子
我们就蹲在地上吃的饭。
蹲一会儿站一会儿。
所以就是很多这种。
就是不专业的东西。
大家可以自己做考量。
你知道我当时发了一个。
跟帐篷相关的朋友圈吗？
然后我们有个听友小雪就留言说。
哎呀这个团不错
还可以锻炼自己搭帐篷的技能。
我就回他说
我说其实不是
我之前跟的商团都是把帐篷搭好的。
比如说像长城币那种。
因为马帮他比较快。
他走到营地的时候。
他已经帮你把帐篷搭好了。
但是这个的话是要自己搭的。
当然他可能会有一些人来帮你。
然后一起搭什么的。
但是搭和收基本上都是要靠自己的。
我并不觉得他会搭我们的帐篷。
但是我有时候就在想说。
小雪说的也有道理。
就是搭帐篷这个技能。
你需要让度给别人吗？
我是不介意自己搭的。
因为我觉得搭帐篷这件事情。
对我来说比较简单。
但我觉得在意的点是。
他们作为就是
理应提供这些装备的一方。
并没有好好地提供这些设备。
就是如果当时我们没有带这个帐篷。
就很有可能出现麻烦。
如果我是另外那两个女生。
他给我提供的是这样的帐篷。
然后连地丁都没有。
而且尤其是他们说在双湖营地的话。
很可能会遇到大风。
那我会比较愤怒吧？
而且说实话
我们这个团的价格并不便宜。
我还想聊一个就是。
可以说是边界感或者是文化冲突的小事。
像在南加取龙营地。
我们团的另外两个女生要跟厨师长。
住一个屋
就是虽然在这条件下。
你没有办法挑剔吧？
但是还是会觉得很不方便。
因为你有时候要换衣服什么的。
然后最后在低蹦营地那天。
早上5点40厨师长就直接进来。
我们屋开始做饭
然后我们只能坐在睡袋里换裤子之类的。
就是他们没有这个意识。
然后还有一件事情。
就是有一天我们在那个窃谈营地生活的时候。
我们都坐在地上烤火。
然后远处不是出现了土锅鼠。
向导就给我们指
然后我说在哪在哪。
我没看见
其中有一个背肤
他就一只手扶在我的腿上。
但是靠近膝盖的位置。
然后另外一只手就给我凑进了。
给我指那个土锅鼠在哪。
就是城市里的人
尤其是女性对于这种身体接触是非常敏感的。
或者说我就是对身体接触很敏感的。
我觉得感觉在城市里就是别说异性了。
就是同性也不太会有这种肢体接触。
是的
有时候我们可能拍拍胳膊 拍拍肩膀。
但是我觉得腿可能是更敏感一些的部位之类的。
我当下就一下反应过来了。
我就觉得会不会是我太敏感了。
但是很快他就把手已开了。
因为他指完了
然后也就持续了几秒钟。
后续我也在想这个事情。
我也在观察他们的动作。
我觉得好像他们对于这种肢体接触的界限。
不像我们这么敏感。
是的
我观察了一下他们的日常生活中。
可能人和人之间的接触。
就是可能肢体触碰会比较多一点。
我感到的界限被打破的有一种不适的感觉。
但是我也理解他们可能没有恶意。
我觉得可能他们整个的生活的方式。
就是他们的行为模式。
就是没有像我们这么人和人之间。
这么明确的界限
因为我记得咱们团和咱们隔壁团。
这两位厨师长他们是亲兄弟。
然后他们相互之间。
虽然都是已经四十好几。
快五十的人了
然后还会揉爆在一起。
就非常亲密
然后我当时就在想说。
我难以想象我爸爸和他的兄弟。
或者是我妈妈和他的姐妹。
有如此亲密的举动。
是的
所以这就是文化的差异。
像上一期古蜀道的时候我们也聊过。
就是人在城市里你的边界感。
界限感
社交距离是很清晰的。
那可能这种某种程度上。
能给你带来安全感和让你舒服。
但是有时候他们这种。
打破了边界的感觉。
也能让你更快的热落起来。
也能拉近人和人彼此之间的距离。
没错
所以这一点其实我想了一下。
要不要聊
因为我好怕被批斗。
我觉得这个其实并不是说。
我们想表达哪种是对的。
或是错的
只不过是一种我们作为一个具体的人。
他是一个亲身的体验和我们的感受。
然后那只不过是想表达出来。
就跟大家说
如果像我们这种在城市里。
特别是在这种大城市。
你在地铁上都会跟人保持。
尽可能远的距离的这种人。
你如果是这样的习惯的话。
你来到这里
可能要做好这样的心理准备。
这个人和人之间的界限。
在这里是更加模糊的。
我觉得我也想提醒一下女孩。
如果你在跟当地的相道接触的过程中。
不管她是言语上的。
还是肢体上的一些接触。
如果让你觉得感到不适的话。
那你就要主动说
没错
不要忍
因为我们也在小红书上刷到。
就是有的女生去徒步的时候。
比如说她坐摩托车下车。
然后也会被司机或是相道拍大腿。
或者是摸手之类的。
而且发生过很多次。
那如果是你不喜欢这种方式。
你就表达出来
或者你就远离
对
哪怕你觉得对方不是恶意的。
但是你感觉不舒服的话。
我觉得你也可以提出来。
没错
然后包括像因为我们这个团是五个女生。
我们当时住伊兹棒的时候。
五个人住一个半夜。
光机门推开了
这个太逗了
然后像到两个大男人出现在门口。
打着手电
然后给你测学养
就是你说他专业吗？
其实还挺专业的
然后剩下的就不知道该如何评了。
这个行为呢？
他也没有敲门
他也半夜也没有灯。
然后黑乎乎的
然后我当时睡觉的时候。
是我带了一个毛线帽。
把那个帽子拉下来。
盖住了眼睛
我就觉得一股强光。
然后我把那个帽子掀上去之后。
只能看到一股强光。
照着我都不知道怎么了。
然后就听有人说伸手。
而且如果我们在里面把门锁上。
他就一直推
一直推一直敲
光光光敲门
不过好在是
就是因为天气比较冷。
大家都穿的比较厚一些。
所以也没有这种特别尴尬的时刻。
对
不过我觉得唯一
百分之百让人挑不出毛病的。
就是他的餐食
就我们那个厨师长。
他每天负责给我们做一顿早饭。
和一顿晚饭
在做的饭都还挺好吃的。
厨艺真的是不错
就是虽然食材比较有限。
但是口味什么的
特别是像我们这种。
从尼泊尔图布回来的。
就是真的完全没得可挑。
虽然我们刚刚一直在吐槽。
整个它的流程什么设置有问题。
但是具体到这些巷岛和厨师。
这些人
他们每个人都是蛮好的。
然后跟我们相处的。
也都蛮愉快的
对
然后这个厨师长
然后每天就在那里慢慢吃。
慢慢吃
对
然后还有餐后水果。
给我们切西瓜吃
然后到了营地
就是吃饭前睡觉前烧热水。
然后给我们送到帐篷前。
这些都做得非常好。
每天晚上都是三菜一汤。
在家水果
两天是西瓜
然后还有苹果和梨什么的。
早饭一般都是粥搭配饼。
或者是像什么西红柿鸡蛋面这种。
我觉得做到这样就已经OK了。
我觉得不需要再给我卷那个餐食了。
不要再更豪华了
我觉得这个饭朴素。
但是好吃
已经非常能满足我的需求了。
对 没错
就是你给我整什么火锅。
什么就是太奢华了。
我会很不舒服
然后说是橡膠吧？
其实这两个橡膠都挺有戏的。
是的
就刚才说了我们前半成后半成。
分别是两个橡膠
然后前半成那个橡膠。
它叫人亲望对
然后它一言以毕之。
就是地鼠家的儿子。
他们家里有正前两百头猫牛。
我第一次看到它我就觉得挺特别的。
因为它带着一个高度近视眼镜。
其实在藏区能看到带近视眼镜的人。
并不是很多
后来我们才知道
因为它画唐卡
对 它们是家事祖传的这种记忆。
就是他爸是非仪
传承人
然后传给了他的哥哥。
因为就是一家只能传一个人。
但是其实他的这个手艺是继承的更好的。
是吗？
他自己这么说的
在这节目里能这么说吗？
会不会调起矛盾
但其实据他说
他画得更好
你这时候的歌
他哥听见了
更有成绩了
他哥会听吗？
因为他还就是什么出门打工。
接上单去画唐卡
类似这种
他有会给寺庙画一些壁画。
什么这种
所以他的眼睛就近视了。
他说他600多
但并不妨碍
他能看到对面很远的山上的金丝猴打架。
是
这个感觉是藏民的天赋。
他们就是能一下子捕捉。
很远很远的对面山坡上。
什么有一个动物
要有一只鸟
就觉得好神奇
包括他给我们讲
他养过一只金丝猴。
你记得吗？
这个真的是一个很。
太魔幻的故事了
就是他也是当相岛的过程中。
可能遇到了一只被母猴子。
抛弃的一个小金丝猴。
他说就是可能水杯大吧？
如果热在山里
可能就活不了了
然后他就捡回来了。
大家也知道金丝猴是国家保护动物。
但是他天高皇帝远的。
也没人知道
他就一直在家里养。
养到了两岁多
那个猴子跟他家里人。
和跟他的关系已经非常好。
而且能听得懂人的指令。
你说你去给我把紙巾拿过来。
他都会去帮你拿
什么的
就已经很通人性的这种了。
结果被人举报了
被人举报了
然后政府还是林业局的人过来。
就是他家要把猴子收走。
但我其实当时在想说。
如果收走的话
我觉得他们可能也不会说。
贸然的就直接放生了。
可能也会收到
比如说就是动物保护机构。
或者是
我觉得起码要经过一些野化训练。
才会再把它放回山里。
然后但是人情
他就不想要别人把他的猴子收走。
他就带着猴子去山里。
然后把猴子放走了。
然后后来他再也没有见过这个猴子。
对
他后来有去山里寻找过这只猴子。
然后呢？
但是也没有找到
也不知道那个猴子后来生活得怎么样了。
哇 这个故事当时听到。
我们几个都要哭了。
特别悲伤
就好像一个电影情节。
对呀 你想那个猴子两年。
其实没有在野外生活过。
他说猴子是一个非常社会化的群体。
你一个外来的陌生的猴子。
他没办法在野外融入他的宗群。
就像我们今年老看日本的那个。
胖气
他想要融入那个猴群。
不就很难吗？
但是我老想那个猴子。
第一天晚上在山里他会不会害怕。
就是从来没有在山里生活过。
然后自己一个人孤独的在山上。
所以这个故事也挺悲伤的。
当时听到
然后我们那个人亲有六个女儿。
这一路上我们就是都在跟他聊。
把他家的耳机本都盘出来了。
他给他老婆买了一百七十多万的首饰。
包括皮草
然后我在我们一生生哇哇的中。
逐渐迷失了自我过。
我们展示了很多他老婆的那种。
就是非常华丽的照片。
什么蜜蜡呀？
天猪啊？
这脑袋打的蜜蜡
包括他的年收入啊？
都被我们套出来了。
然后他说他曾经出门打工了一年。
挣了三十万
原因是因为他之前在家里打牌。
一晚上输了二十八万。
不得已出门打工去把这个钱挣回来。
确实他的收入算在藏民里算很高的了。
因为他是首一人嘛？
你想想就是一头毛牛差不多在一万上下。
可能按大小
他家有将近两百头。
他说他要拼命工作。
因为他有六个女儿。
在藏区的话
女孩出嫁是要赔嫁毛牛和一些珠宝的。
他有把他六个女儿的这些东西准备好。
然后他还跟我们说说。
跟女儿说要找汉人结婚。
这样子就不用出那么多陪嫁了。
但是他女儿挺有出息的。
他有两个女儿都已经在念大学了。
对一个在天津
一个在拉萨
他还是就是很注重。
比如说小孩的教育上学这些事情。
所以就感觉跟他聊得还挺逗的。
而最逗的是我们走着走着。
翻过牙口之后看到了几头毛牛。
然后他忽然跟我们说。
是我家的毛牛跑出来了。
他居然能隔那么远一眼。
认出就是他们自己家的毛牛。
就没有任何标识
不是说毛牛上就打了一个。
什么颜色的耳环之类的这种事情。
没有
他能认出来
他说他们家毛牛的尾巴比较短。
还是怎么着
我们会觉得这个螺子跟那个螺子。
看起来差不多
除非这是一匹白马。
对
很特别
或者是一个白毛牛。
黑毛牛你觉得看着都差不多。
他老远就说
那是我们家的牛
我以为他在开玩笑呢？
然后他拿手机把画面拉大。
拉了很大
他说这就是我们家的牛。
一开始是发现了五只吧？
后来翻过了牙口
又发现了几只
一共十三只
他说他老婆应该要在家急死了。
不知道这些牛跑到哪去了。
我说那你怎么办
他说那个牛
国庆节就会自己回家。
我说那你的牛跑去人家的牧场吃草。
没关系吗？
他说没关系
太好笑了
所以对他们之间的这种。
边界感和这种划分。
有时候很清晰
就比如说谁家的牧场绝对不能碰。
然后就是什么？
两边的巷岛要交接。
但是这个牛跑来跑去又没有关系。
我觉得他是个挺聪明的人。
而且他长得有点像棚蕾。
我们就说他是藏地文青。
对呀？
因为他又会画画
然后唱歌还好听
就是经常走着走着就开始放声歌唱。
对
什么巷岛
太好听了
我说那你的牛跑去人家的牧场。
憔 showcase。
ender
因为他普通话也还行。
人也挺有趣的
有很多故事呀什么的。
就一路走一路跟我讲故事。
抖他的家底呀什么的。
讲一些好玩的东西。
所以这一路也还挺有趣的。
是
就是整个人穿衣服比较腩。
我们其实也感慨
就是感觉藏族同胞。
他们花钱的方式跟我们不太一样。
他们会把钱花在一些很大的地方。
全是大块的支出
比如说他买一个天珠。
好几十万
然后买一批赛马
像当地人很喜欢买赛马。
买一批赛马甚至会到上百万。
把钱全都用在重的地方。
然后有一些小的地方。
比如说我们觉得
你是不是能买个好点的冲锋衣。
或者羽绒服
你都已经在做巷导了。
我买一条好点裤子。
那裤子都已经烂成那样了。
或者买上好点的
改善自己生活的某些东西。
他们好像不太会把钱花在这些地方。
跟我们的消费观念不太一样。
我们在城市里头
你会觉得很多细碎的地方要花钱。
你今天点没奶茶
明天点个咖啡
你这些小的钱一下就没了。
然后他们都是买大件。
就他们那些大件花起来。
我们听起来真的是。
离谱
就是非常令人称目结舌。
但是他们又在日常的生活中。
非常不拘小节
然后我们的第二个巷导。
格桑加错
就不是地主家的儿子了。
就感觉他明显可能凭自己奋斗一些。
第二个巷导是21岁。
一个年轻的小孩
他是沙多村当地的村民。
然后他是家里的独生子。
其实这挺少见的
因为藏族很少只生一个孩子。
我觉得有一些比较冲击我的时刻。
他们结婚都特别早。
就是有一个巷导
看起来特别不着调的那个巷导。
我以为他可能就20出头。
结果他已经40了。
然后他13岁结的婚。
男巷导
13岁结的婚
孩子都已经可以当巷导了。
他自己不愿意去走的时候。
他就把他18岁的孩子支出去。
让他孩子去当巷导。
像我们第二个巷导21岁。
他说像他这样没结婚。
没生孩子已经是少数了。
像他身边什么17岁的女孩。
已经是两个孩子的妈了。
都已经很正常了
我知道藏族人可能结婚生孩子比较早。
但我没想到还是这么早。
就是可能14 5岁就已经开始结婚了。
他给我们讲的几个故事。
你登上牙口以后不能大喊大叫。
否则会下雨
就是他们当地的洗俗。
然后还有就是在神湖里。
你不能打水漂
不能往里头扔石头。
因为也会下雨
他说他原来小时候挖虫草。
不想挖
就跑到那个湖边
往里疯狂扔石头
希望下雨这样就可以回家了。
然后有一天下大雨。
我们去看湖
湖实在是没什么可看的了。
然后他就说带着我们挖虫草。
然后你就看见六个人在风雨中。
大雾中
西风苦雨
在那个山坡上游荡。
云亦在低头寻找
其实我们也不知道在找什么？
因为没有见过真虫草。
结果也一根都没找着。
我们有一天翻那个真拉牙口的时候。
就是因为雾实在是太大了。
就什么都看不到
然后他就在不停地吹口哨。
我说你吹什么口哨。
他说这个就是驱风的口哨。
但我听起来其实很像是鸟叫。
就他那个口哨的声音就特别像是那种。
你知道有时候下过雨。
马上要云开雾散的时候。
就会听到鸟开始叫。
我觉得跟那个声音很像。
包括在双湖营地的时候。
早上起来不是起雾了吗？
我们那个厨师他也在罕山。
然后当时露了一下可以放进来。
就是他喊山
他是觉得能把那个雾喊走。
但是当时确实他喊完以后。
那个对面的山就清晰了很多。
对很神奇
然后就是这个家错。
我们第二个相当
他其实自己是有在计划去。
做自己的线路的
然后以他的计划来说的话。
就是等于
可以直接从沙多村进出。
然后第一天就直接去看柔错。
然后把这几个精华线去串起来。
因为其实从地崩营地。
可以是最近去看柔错的地方。
可以当天往返
然后包括像什么南加曲龙。
以及好几个牙口都可以。
以地崩为这个
其中点给他串联起来。
就不用说走这个穿越路线了。
然后他还给我们讨论。
这个路线可行性
包括他们错误其实。
今年也把路修得更好了。
有一些路线
原来是轨迹不太容易发现。
因为它很窄
然后现在他们把路都拓宽了。
然后修了新的路
包括像有些地方都已经。
大部分能拓摩托车了。
像那个柔错牙口
它下来的那个碎石路段很陡。
他们还在旁边
加了一些就是缆绳。
这样子你可以手拉一些什么的。
就觉得
也确实他们村市
想好好来做这个路线。
主要就是交通太不方便了。
否则如果从沙多进村的话。
我们其实想了一下。
也确实是一个可行的路线。
说说路线吧？
其实我们走的过程中一直觉得。
这50公里
没有必要分成六天走。
可能也是因为下雨吧？
你太早到营地了以后下雨。
也没事可干
这个无聊的时间就被拉长了。
如果天气好的话
可能也还行
你到了营地休息休息。
看看风景什么的
就没觉得那么难熬。
你像我们走的话
有一天甚至12点就到营地了。
下午大半天的时间。
都不知道干吗？
对
其实跟我们同期
我们也陆续续看到。
一些重桩的朋友
他们反而会选择
每天走更长的路线。
可能也是因为我们之前。
比较相信商团
他的路线的设置
所以也没自己
再去做研究
否则的话
如果我们自己选择的话。
可能每天也会选择。
更长的路线
对 因为我们毕竟是清桩。
然后我看了一下石头走的。
它是走的四天
我感觉这个是
稍微比较合理的
我觉得踏踏翁
就是一个天气好的话。
你会觉得怎么着都行。
怎么着都好
天气不好的话
就一切都打回原形的。
这种一个地方
或者说是高海拔的地方。
都是这样的
太吃天气了
我们当时走的时候。
一直在说
同情石头
成为石头
质疑石头
对
天气好的时候吃吃路三。
然后休息休息
你拍拍照
拍照的时间也会拉长。
你可能走路就不会那么赶。
然后你到了银地
没下雨的话
你慢慢优优优的
把帐篷打起来
然后换个银地鞋
然后在草地上晒着太阳。
你泡个茶
吃点零食
看看书也好
或者你拉伸一下也好。
就是这个咸侠的时间。
会比较容易渡过
包括有一天
加厕所说要带我们跳锅装。
对
然后类似这样
你就很容易打发时间。
如果一下雨的话
就完全是另外一种景象了。
你在雨里手忙脚乱地搭帐篷。
然后你搭完帐篷以后。
所有东西都是湿的潮的。
然后你只能坐在帐篷里。
你连帐篷的拉锁都不能拉开。
你只能躺在里头
因为我这次也没带书。
我后来怎么打发时间。
我躺在帐篷里
我看帐篷顶上的水珠。
我就猜那两个水珠。
会聚在一块
会聚在一块以后
它留下来是留两条长线。
还是一条长线
我就自己在心里
跟自己在这独博
这已经无聊到这种程度。
我就想到那个风岛美术馆。
地上的那个水珠
你还理会讲
想一会困了
睡觉
有一天下午
甚至睡了两觉
到了尹地以后
除了睡觉就是睡觉。
我是带了一本书
然后全城把这本书看完了。
但还挺蛮厚的一本书。
你在雨里收帐篷也很崩溃。
你手都冻浆了
然后尤其是我们的那个駝包。
因为要尝试些淋雨。
它没有那么防水
所以他们最后
每个人给我们发了一个。
画肥袋套在外面
套那个画肥袋和取那个画肥袋。
也很费劲
我觉得这也是他们不专业的一点。
因为按理说马帮
他都要有一个更大的袋子。
给他集体装在一起。
他们并没有
所以你做完这一切。
你收完帐篷
然后又把你的行李收拾好。
又套在那个画肥袋里。
扎上口子
你这一切做完
已经进脾力进了
你就觉得特别的不耐烦。
然后你在走线的时候。
又刮风下雨
啥风你也看不到
你就一直怀疑人生。
你就觉得我为什么要在这。
我在干嘛？
在做防雨装备测试。
尤其是头一天晚上。
屋子还漏雨
然后还没睡好的话。
而且包括下雨的时候。
上厕所很麻烦
如果你只是尿一个还好一点。
因为时间短
你就淋一会就淋一会。
但是你要是拉湿
你就得带着伞
你说这个伞
你是遮头顶上的雨。
还是你遮屁股
屁股
只有第一天的衣子蹦影帝。
是有厕所的
那个厕所是没有顶的。
而且它只到你的人的一半。
就是你得蹲下来脱股子。
你不能站着脱
当时我们还嫌弃这个厕所。
但是没想到这个厕所。
已经是最好的条件了。
后面就是所有的都没有厕所。
你只能找石头
而且你会发现
这块可能有点恶心。
隐蔽性非常好的地方。
就会
全部都已经被先人站了。
我没有个朋友
甚至会叮嘱后去的人说。
你不要踩到我的屎。
而且那些地方
基本上都是很不平整的。
你可能是在石头堆上。
然后那个石头还不稳。
你还要一边利用自己的。
大腿的臀部的力量。
控制住什么的
到后面上厕所
真的太困难了
我觉得最难的
其实是在最后一晚。
在地崩营地
因为其他的地方
都是比较空旷一些。
你可能找一个隐蔽的地方。
或者找一个大石头。
或者找一个树叢
都可以
但是在地崩营地
它是一间屋
挨一间屋
挨一间屋的
它其实类似一种村子吧？
全部都是那种
简易的铁皮房
对 地崩其实是沙多村。
他们村民挖虫草的。
虫草营地
然后它又没有
大石头这种遮挡的地方。
你只能越走越远
越走越高
因为你不能随便找一个地方。
因为随便找一个地方。
就会对着别人家的窗口。
对
所以还是夜幕降临以后。
会比较好
就是一直在等天黑。
这个上厕所
真的是有点太费劲了。
这里我们
后来也讨论了一下。
就为什么不能修一个。
室内的背上间
然后当时我们还说。
就是我们这个巷岛。
加措
他想做自己的线路。
我们就说
如果他能在那里开一个。
带室内卫生间的民宿。
绝对所有人都会选他家。
反正上厕所这个事。
就是必须要克服一下的。
但是因为下雨
让上厕所这件事情。
变得更难了
插出去一个话题
就关于这个厕所的。
当时
三三我们俩还讨论来着。
因为他之前
加过的一个巷岛
在哈萨克斯坦徒步。
然后就是今年不是好多人。
去徒步哈萨克斯坦。
那边的天山
然后他就说
那个线路非常野
但是
沿途都有避难小屋。
所有翻越打板的
上下都有避难小屋。
他说
就是所有的这些
就是你线路可以很野。
但是这种基础的设施。
反而给你配备的很齐。
那我们这一期
其实就聊了一下
他念他翁的基本的情况。
其实想到哪儿
聊到哪儿
比较细碎
然后反正大家也听出来了。
我们就是有很多感受。
是
然后下一期
我们可能就按照
我们每天走的形成。
来聊一聊
然后包括
装备
带了什么？
没带什么？
应该要带什么？
建议带什么这些
我们再聊一聊这些。
好的
那这期先这样了
拜拜
me clouds chase。
every one from the place。
come on with that rain。
I've a smile on my face。
I walk down the lane。
with a happy refrain。
and I'm singing。
just singing in the rain。
by bwd6